elle le crack indre supérieur de santé
et trésorier du syndicat national des
sapeurs pompiers professionnels
bonjour il ya le cra merci de répondre à
nos questions sur arte france quelle est
la réalité du quotidien de vos confrères
dans cette période si spécial écoutez
notre réalité c'est que l'on s'inscrit
dans les efforts qui seront faits par
par tous les soignants et les
intervenants auprès des populations
cependant nous faisons face comme
partout à des pénuries en termes de
matériel alors même si les stocks
semblent garantis
c'est pas partout c'est pas aussi
évident que ça d'un point de vue
opérationnel et nous avons des
difficultés à obtenir des masques pour
la totalité de nos interventions et nous
adaptons nos procédures de manière à
exposer le moins possible nos personnels
mais c'est tout de même assez
problématique d'obtenir le matériel et
de gérer cette crise qui est vraiment
hors normes et foule bien vous bien me
dire justement est ce que vous sentez
suffisamment protégés face à l'épidémie
dans l'exercice de vos fonctions
écoutez le printemps dans les
communications des grands dignitaires
dans les consignes qui sont données
force est constater que les pompiers ne
font pas forcément considérée comme un
service public
à l'instar de département fanion alors
nous ne sommes pas comme les personnages
payante première ligne du bus ou
indirecte nous sommes exposés puisque
nous allons chercher les victimes chez z
également et notre activité quotidienne
ne t'arrête pas et vous continuez à un
pet une part importante de secours à
personnes et nous avons des difficultés
vraiment à nous à nous sentir et pour
les administrations les consignes sont
assez tardive assez générales un exemple
les consignes notamment des gardes
d'enfants ne s'applique pas sa part
confié les consignes en cas d'arrêt
maladie font que tu es dans ton pied
auront encore un jour de carence en cas
d'arrêt maladie
donc ce sont des sanctions prises envers
soignants ne sont pas reportées
l'allaitement pompiers ça commence à me
poser interrogations très sérieusement
vous parlez de la pénurie des masques 1
pendant que vous parlez à vos côtés on a
vu des images d'edouard philippe le
premier ni ce qu'a annoncé ce matin
devant les députés que le gouvernement
va faire tester des masques alternatif
est ce que ça va dans le bon sens
l'on vous bien ce que c'est le signe
d'une tergiversation de la part de
l'exécutif
écoutez c'est le signe d'un besoin
énorme en équipements de protection
individuelle pour faire face au co vide
on a tiré sur les budgets des sa vie
publique pendant des années et ben il
faut
très clairement on n'a pas les stocks en
quantité suffisante pour être vraiment à
l'aise et il faut que l'on que l'on
adapte notre réponse en fonction en
fonction des stocks qui sont disponibles
les stocks que l'on adapte pour
l'essentiel de la tonne de l'épidémie de
h1n1 et c'est assez ancien et très
clairement il ya des machines
actuellement périlleux qui risque d'être
utilisés on a des solutions hydro
alcooliques qui sont parfois également
péri mais y compris dans les écoles de
l'état qui sont utilisés parce qu'on n'a
pas d'autre stoppe donc on gère la
situation évidemment on adapte nos
procédures évidemment volonté de
protéger au maximum nos personnels et on
arrivait à faire le job je dirais mais
il faudra bien après la crise et c'est
pas l'heure de la polémique il faudra
bien après la crise que l'on compte les
points je dirais et que je vous pose des
questions qui sont celles de
l'approvisionnement celle de la
préparation à la crise est celle du
financement de la crise ces sept en
championnat difficulté c'est que la
libre administration des collectivités
laisse aux départements le choix de
l'organisation le foie de la
priorisation et les finances ils étaient
dans ce cas ce sont ses choix
d'anticipation pour des événements plus
faibles occurrence main parfois on est
fait à la linière seuls 2 de l'équilibré
budgétaire et elle le cra vous dites
qu'il faudra tirer les conséquences
après la crise mais pendant cette crise
sanitaire agnès buzyn ex-miss de la
santé edouard philippe
le premier ministre sont attaqués en
justice par un collectif de médecins
pour je cite négligence coupable
votre position ma position est celle de
nos syndicats c'est qu'actuellement nous
avons à gérer la crise on se positionne
sur les quais vraiment opérationnel
l'important c'est de poids des secours à
nos concitoyens et de participer à
l'effort collectif de la nation face à
ces tech l'épidémie
sur ce plan en particulier je pense que
ça viendra dans un second temps mai
dernier pas à cette politique des
syndicats de police menace d'utiliser
leur droit de retrait s'ils ne sont pas
équipés de masques et de matériel de
protection suffisant
quelle est la police la position des
sapeurs pompiers
par rapport à cela est ce que vous
pouvez menacé également d'utiliser votre
droit de retrait je fais pas pompier
c'est d'aller d'aller au contact moi je
dois saluer l'enfant des personnels
volontaires qui qui s'investissent et
les personnes qui comptent mais on ne
leur ait des personnels d'être actif
techno spécialisé sur l'aéropole comme
en outre-mer parce qu'on ne faut pas
oublier que cet acteur d'outre-mer sont
aussi impactés
le droit de retrait c'est pas une
question pour nous on va faire le
travail
évidemment on va essayer de se protéger
au maximum il y aura certainement la
situation en local quitteront très tendu
où des situations qui seront compliqués
on fera de boulot mais effectivement la
question de la protection du personnel
et d'anticipation elle se posera très
clairement merci à le cra d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes
cadre supérieur de santé et trésorier du
syndicat national des sapeurs pompiers
professionnels